it's been just a gift just even to
follow your Instagram
the the winter you the window you create
on the on this part of the world
uh it's just really beautiful I I do
want to ask on that
maybe it's like uh behind the scenes a
little bit but like how do you keep the
equipment dry like how do you
like how hard
is bringing equipment to the cameras
you're an incredible filmmaker and
photographer so how do you make it work
I don't know it's not that hard we we
really it's not that bad what it is wet
the new iPhones are waterproof and if
they don't get I'm telling you dude it's
been such a weapon it's been awesome
um if you drop it in the river my one
thing is you gotta have a tether because
I drop it all the time and so I'll be
hanging off a boat I'll be trying to
take a video and I'll be like here we
are in the Amazon you can see the login
Funk yeah that's the biggest thing but
the the we shoot on cannons
and uh
I don't know it's worked out it's not
that bad oh really so you can keep the
equipment dry I keep the equipment dry
and I actually don't a lot of people put
their in silica at night and like
keep it dry and then they take it out
and I find that when you do that the
temperature chain change creates
moisture inside the camera so what I do
is I never do that I just keep my
cameras in my backpack with a zipper so
they're more or less exposed to the
elements yeah and so it sort of always
has a little bit of equilibrium
and that's it I mean I shoot on some
pretty fancy equipment sometimes and and
it's great but I mean the awesome thing
though now is that like with with with a
cell phone I mean like I like I like put
my phone down on the ground a few weeks
ago and like let this rhino like walk up
to it and stuff and it's like you can
get video footage that you can literally
put on Netflix like it's just like it's
it's getting really exciting and that's
where like
um right where I deviate from the the
nature people that are like we need to
go back and live in cabins I'm like dude
this is awesome and I love taking
slow-mos like like no way it makes you
reappreciated but just by yourself just
reappreciate over and over and over and
then you can also share it with the
world well that's the thing is sharing
it with people there's nothing better
than like
teaching a kid to catch a fish you know
and like and like in in a way Instagram
has allowed us to do that where it's
like I can have this crazy ass moment
that that is so unique and then and then
put it up for people to see you know or
I mean I remember one of the most recent
things that got people you never know
what's going to get people excited
um I literally just like there was like
you know 3 000 butterflies on the beach
and they were like black red and blue
beautiful butterflies and I just like
panned the phone across it and then like
jumped in the river and swam away and
like threw that up on Instagram and
people went berserk they're like this is
the most amazing thing like four
different accounts reached out to try
and share it and I was like butterflies
they're everywhere there's four thousand
species of butterfly in the Amazon like
but but sharing that with people is is
beautiful how do you find the thing to
shoot how do you how do you come up with
the butterflies how do you notice the
thing that's beautiful and say I'm gonna
wait a minute like pause this is
beautiful let me take a let me let me
take a picture of this because like
sometimes you might get used to yeah the
beauty right yeah yeah or like sometimes
simple crazy things like like leaf
cutter ants yeah they're just walking by
they become it becomes pedestrian it's
like well I mean just like when you're
you know you're living at the elephant
camp and it's like the elephant comes
out and he starts like trashing the
water bucket where like would just stop
yeah we're trying to watch peaky
blinders here so yeah just leave us
alone it becomes normal after a while
yeah um
uh but no in the jungle I don't I don't
that's never a struggle for me because
as a photographer it's like whenever my
eye hits on something I went I've never
seen that many of those butterflies all
the same species together and like this
oh yeah I'm trying to get this one thing
that the butterflies do is in the dry
season the salt deposits you'll get like
three or four maybe five thousand
butterflies
all coming onto this one area of sand
because there'll be like some leaching
there'll be some some salt deposit there
or something
and they'll all be Wings flat against
the ground with their with their
proboscises on the sand and if you go
walk near them they will Vortex up and
you have a rainbow Vortex of butterflies
and you can like go run through that
and it's surreal and I want to what I
want to do is get the shot where I I
guess leave the phone recording in
slow-mo facing up
and leave it there for an hour let the
butterflies come in and settle and then
disturb them so I get the bottom of the
vortex of the bug I'm like these are the
ways I think where I'm like how can I
show people the absolute mind-blowing
you know with an eye Perfection it's
amazing I mean that's what I have you
know I'm sure that somebody else could
do it with you know a red and and nail
it but it's like that's what I have in
the jungle because I have to travel
light and I you know yeah I think that
that that really that works I have the
same thing when I was traveling in
Ukraine
you can go to Warzone it doesn't matter
it doesn't like uh it has to do with the
you're talking about like with the like
protecting your camera or not it feels
like the more you protect stuff the more
it's gonna get
damaged yeah like so like see like my
cameras they're all missing this is like
this is amazing to me so all my cameras
are missing the they're all how you can
see the metal through the paint nice so
all this and so like they're all because
I'm constantly like I'll like slide in
and like take a picture and like they're
banged up but these they're good they're
good machines I think they get tough
over time if you put them through it's
like the immune system like it's like
muscles it's like David Goggins cameras
if you gotta you gotta make them suffer
every day